n'oubliez pas ceci n'est pas du tout une
calvitie naissante et bienvenue dans
cette vidéo comment allez-vous je m'en
fous l'âge de pierre ça veut dire
quelque chose quand l'humain a commencé
à confectionner et d'utiliser des outils
pour agrandir son choix des possibles
pour optimiser son temps et sa
rentabilité
mais écoutez c'est le suivi de ce
président aujourd'hui isabelle spécial
hadj tunes et ça traite justement de sa
de tous les outils qu'on a créé inventé
pour des trucs très spécifique du bloc
ont au plus incroyable et c'est génial
alors comme what people d'einstein c'est
un sport d'élite qui est très souvent
mis à jour il ya souvent beaucoup de
fautes nouveau c'est pour ça que j'aime
bien suivre et surtout tu apprend plein
de choses tout en tapant débarras épouse
de casque logitech en mayenne itunes my
my little i'm the micros nm ready
to react clean up mais six brasil sa
mauvaise idée celui-là il est drôle mais
c'est un mauvais exemple c'est un outil
qui a été créé dans le but 2 allez-y
vous avez vous c'était même pas dans les
trois propositions je vous piège
maintenant c'est pour ranger vos
spaghetti tombé de l'assiette en vrai
c'est sympa secrètement j'aimerais
laisser y est bon ici c'est un toc est
très long mais en gros c'est un piège à
souris rats sauf qu'au lieu
d'emprisonner les ryd les buts et balla
il meurt pas juste eu les capturent
vivants et ensuite tu vas les fous très
loin de chez toi
regardez et c'est chao la bête pourquoi
enrichir des compagnies énorme de
dératisation quand vous avez besoin
juste d'un morceau de carton et d'un
seau et comment comme à noël elle peut
pas tomber dans le piège ça vient
d'arriver à tous mes copains tu peux pas
tomber dedans c'est facilement bons
rails à la fin du coup de la vidéo
assurons la phobie des 2g pas prévenu je
vous préviens maintenant attention voilà
on est sur une belle capture une belle
prise
c'est trop bien je trouve pour capturer
des rats sans avoir à les tuer voilà je
trouvais ça cool
[Musique]
non impossible
ça existe vraiment ces fameuses outil
qui a dans les films pour trouver le
code d'un coffre fort chez pas quoi je
me suis toujours dit que c'est de la
pure connerie ça existe
j'en veux je vais moto braquer je m'en
fous et en plus il fait tourner ça avec
la ligne de ton pc hp un peu pété qui
fait pas trop tourner le jeu de la balle
tu remover un outil pour déplacer des
arbres on va déplacer des arbres non on
va déplacer des forêts entières avec
l'art millet et ils nous ont ramenés
d'afrique au nez on dirait les arbres tu
vois dans les paysages africains de ses
très beau très grand à moins que je ne
porte quoi weeding machine c'est quoi
vous du désherbage j'ai envie d'essayer
qu'ils voulaient que je lui dise de plus
j'ai envie d'essayer
imaginez faire ça avec cinq de vos potes
avant d'aller en soirée le rêve level in
times
c'est quoi ta dans là je prends
un coup là carrelage carrelage même
temps mais quand je parle anglais je
parle pas trop d'herbe ou carrelage je
comprends rien je suis pas bricoleur
j'ai pas la réf
je sais pas oui oui ok c'est plein de
petits trucs bleus avec un truc entre à
se divertir et du coup aucun qui a
compris à temps mais je suis si le nom
ne dit pas que c'est j'espère que c'est
pas la honte de ne pas avoir compris
assez pour équilibrer à ok j'ai excusez
moi oui je peux vous déranger pendant
que vous êtes en train de bitche et sur
moi puisque je suis inculte ok ça sert
juste à équilibrer le niveau des plaques
pour ton carla choix bien droit à un
ceux qui habitent chez sept chats ou
changer de vidéos ça dégage omate
contours gauche fort florine project
j'ai rien compris je comprends très peu
aujourd'hui un seul plein moi je les
peins j'ai clairement pas celle là dès
que c'est un truc de bricolage ne l'est
pas c'est fou quand même il faut que je
mette au bricolage mac c'est horrible
c'est incroyable comme si un jour je
dois me débrouiller pour survivre je
suis mort mais je suis vraiment foutu
j'en suis au stade où si on me retire du
mérite je perds 10 kg la mechanical
chaîne manufacturing
waouh ça m'impressionne des trucs comme
ça c'est quoi le but final genre de tous
ces mouvements tous ces mécanismes
[Musique]
à sa fabrique une chaîne voit c'est
tellement satisfaisant mec c'est
tellement satisfaisant
c'est comme ça que tu as une chaîne et
l'huile les fermes ou alors quand je dis
qu'on apprend des trucs sagres annonce
now clearing machine for trucks un outil
dont l'unique but est de retirer la
neige qui s'est posé sur lesquels et
pourquoi il ya besoin de retirer la
meije absolument qui s'est posé sur les
camions et ben on aura pas cette réponse
aujourd'hui en tout cas alors à pour
simuler peu importe d'où le soleil vient
en fait waouh c'est pour les architectes
ça ça j'adore comme ça intéressant c'est
incroyable effectivement ils doivent
penser au soleil comment ils tapent sur
la maison où l'immeuble que l'architecte
est en train de créer du coup ils ont
une table spécifique pour ce à quoi qui
simule tous les placements possible du
soleil et du coup comment ça affecte le
bâtiment c'est génial j'adore plus de ça
moi s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
ça c'est du live axa il a mis un bout de
balai sur une perceuse mexes et ça
marche très fort par contre attention là
ça marche très très fort bien plus qu'on
ne le pensait ping-pong ball connector
oh non mais voilà tous ceux qui jouent
au ping pong ou qui n'aiment pas ça a
fermé les oreilles 10 comme des eaux est
d'accord la pire chose au ping pong
c'est que à la fin tu es fatigué non pas
parce que tu as joué mais parce que tu
t'es accroupi et relevé 400 fois durant
le match pour ramasser les balles non
mais c'est vrai quoi je pas si vous avez
remarqué
enfin en podcast nu
[Musique]
j'achète cette machine s'appelle vache
est heureuse elle rend vraiment les
vagins heureuse mais faites pas ça
appelez-nous à la place nous on vient
les caresser volontiers vos vaches
appelez-nous je suis jaloux de cet outil
hautement spécialisés et sous apprécié
c'est si vrai ça referme la porte son
côté à le faire et en plus ça n'empêche
de claquer mais vous en rendez compte
quand c'est sorti toute la ccsa devait
être fou ou mal an nous ils sont
omniprésents y en a partout autour de
nous et on les ignore on est ingrat on
est pitoyable voilà la vérité vous
trouvez que je vais loin pour un truc
qui ferme les portes automatiques mans
peut-être dispositif pour repousser les
échelles par david j'adore l'évolution à
l'époque ont cherché comment faire
tomber les échelles des gens qui
venaient pour débuter aujourd'hui on
cherche comment faire pour que ces
porte se referme tout seul et
qu'on gagne 3 secondes
non mais c'est vrai quoi ce petit bâton
rouge est utilisée par les ouvriers
agricoles pour ne récolter que des
poivrons parfaitement mûrs pour la sauce
tabasco soit c'est vrai et c'est
incroyable soit c'est un coup de com et
ses incroyables florman cleaner non mais
tu pas que ça nettoie gens ni quel ton
tapis et compris s'il est plein de poils
de chebaa les tapis de ma voiture sont
dégueulasses mec
cg est ce que ça existe en france tu es
bien le pdg d'une entreprise qui a créé
ça mais pour la force
oui alors de nous la drees vos choix
réutilisables en uréthane pour bétons
décoratifs de solo mon corps est unique
c'est cool frère mais vraiment personne
entre nous ne coule jamais du béton mais
c'est cool
blablabla on peut pas s'en passer
voilà hier j'ai fait dans la clarté
manger des conditions voilà typiquement
le genre d'outils que je méprise
typiquement nommé rendez leur leur
gloire merde à la fin on s'est trop
habitués là ça va pas le mec qui a
inventé ça le gac celui là celui qui l'a
inventé j'ai en fait j'adore voit à quel
point à une époque il n'y a pas l'outil
n'a pas encore été créée on est nickel
on vit très bien comme ça il ya un mec
qui se dit imagine genre le cornichon on
tire comme ça et ça les ramènent hors du
jeu à la surface serait pas grave mieux
que tel et galérer comme ça que tu dois
au fond du pot on optimise to make c'est
incroyable la cinquième roue non arrêtez
vos trucs d'agent secret l'a arrêté ça
me séduit trop non arrêté c'est trop là
non c'est trop nom me dis pas que ça
facilite au créneau je n'y crois pas ça
facilite son créneau oui oui oui et pour
sortir pareil mais mais c'est
génial on avait sans 1950 et là
on a plus qu est ce qui s'est passé
bordel pourquoi fallait le garder mec
on allait trop loin c'est critique je
river ça me dérange je comprends levin
électrique sinon elle à elle son dead
mais l'hélicoptère quoi quel est ton
métier de pilote d hélicoptère auquel je
suspends une tronçonneuse géant pour
couper des arbres et toits
moi je fais des vidéos où je réagis je
gagne d'argent frais sur gk structure
traîne pas
wae mais ça c'est paris sa ceux
qui sont en étude là pour pour devenir
chirurgien action en médecine mais
montrez nous tout ça sur twitter veut on
veut voir et ça simule plusieurs types
de plaies avec des ouvertures plus ou
moins grande en plus c'est trop bien
fait péter ce genre d'infos sur twitter
on veut voir passer ça c'est hyper
intéressant tu te fous de ma gueule
un train de 580 tonnes qui peut passer
des ponts dans lesquelles il ya des
trous pour amener la suite du rail tu te
fous de ma gueule c'est incroyable ça
j'adore quand tu découvres commence on
fait des choses que tu as ou menée
depuis que tu es tout petit tu t'es
jamais posé la question au fait tu n'as
pas idée à quel point ces recrues c'est
vraiment dingue
qu'est ce que c'est que ça un gun pour
but et les mouches on en est là on met
au point un gun pour but et des insectes
mal et se tissent du sel mois mais que
j'ai acheté la raquette là électrique je
me sentais tellement frais il a inventé
au pistolet qui envoie du sel sur la
mouche et qui l'assomment jusqu'où ça
ira
eh bien les amis merci à tous je sais je
sais vous avez envie d'acheter au moins
un dixième de ce qu'on a vu dans cette
vidéo je cite certains voudront acheter
le guen pour nick et les mouches
d'autres voudront plutôt acheté le truc
qui permet de construire des rails en
hauteur bref ça ça dépend les bourses
chacun une bourse différentes mais
franchement c'était pas grave
intéressant vous avez fait le nombre de
trucs que tu apprends en fait c'est trop
con univers ludique en vrai comme ça
brille dès que je trouve génial j'ai une
question dans tout ça quand même c'est
quand qu'on invente un outil pour tes
cheveux tombent plus quand est-ce qu'il
arrive cet outil est ce que cette vidéo
est en réalité qu'un appel à l'aide
qu'ils sont savoure cette folie pour
simplifier toutes les tâches et toujours
être plus dans la performance la
performance d'optimisation la
performance est incroyable et de course
à l'optimisation comprend des trucs
énormes qui nous arrangent tout genre
pourra faire des rails aux auteurs
encore une fois je parle de ça mais
c'était intéressant il ya des trucs
tellement absurde aussi tellement bête
mais qui nous arrange beaucoup aimé
qu'ils sont tellement genre c'est cette
c'est rocher pas où est la limite du
dans là c'est trop lassés bon ça va ça
on peut le faire quand même je sais pas
alors mais là je lance un débat qui est
bien plus grand qui me dépasse
complètement
athènes une prochaine vidéo je vais
installer le truc qui est ferme la porte
ça m'a vraiment donné allez à bientôt
[Musique]